vidé moi j'aimerais j'aimerais
j'aimerais aussi qu'on revienne aussi au
sujet euh afficher les dcanss sur les
réseaux sociaux a-t-il R pour moi il a
et je le dis et c'est pas bien de le
dire mais je devrais pas le dire mais
pour moi et vous avez tout à fait raison
parce qu'à un moment il y a plus de
solution vous le voyez bien on le voit
tous les soirs ici alors si où on écoute
Gilles Verdez et on fait rien et à un
moment et ben il va y avoir des drames
ou bien on essaie de faire quelque chose
et on essaie de faire du mieux qu'on
peut pour éviter les drames et éviter
qui voilà que les gens se fassent
justice même parce que ça pour moi c'est
mieux que de se faire justice soême
voilà c'est c'est parce que ça aurait pu
être plus grave êre aussi des mecs qui
fassent un moment tu sais avec un moment
les mecs ils ont plus de solution un
moment ça va être ça va être autre chose
que des photos donc il vaut mieux passer
par les photos et passer par les mecs
qui disent voilà ces mecs là ils ont
foutu le bordel oui oui g contrairement
à toi moi je crois que l'augmentation de
la violence n'est pas une fatalité toi
tu dis on baisse les bras tu dis
toujours c'est impossible à si tu jour
sur grand c'est impossible à
faireoss
jeunèreénér poures leses quimettent
deutter contre l'amentation de la
crialité les caméras l'augmentation des
caméras dans la ville pour démasquer
ceux qui ont fait des conneries et aussi
ce genre d'initiative voilà parce que
j'estime que les victimes non plus à se
taire et qu'on doit afficher ceux qui
font foutent la merde P moi je pense en
MO je te le dis il y a pas moi je suis
pas dire j'accepte pas aussi voilà de
dire c'est les Maghrébins c'est c'est
les mecs de l'Est c'est les mecs c'est
surtout les mecs qui viennent en bande
en fait quel qu'il soit je te le dis
même moi quand je suis on va pas se
mentir quand quand tu es avec des potes
et ben tu tu penses qu' a un truc c'est
fait y en a un qui fait une connerie tu
veux faire encore une connerie encore
plus grosse que lui c'est ça c'est c'est
truc c'est ça bah non mais c'est vrai je
pense qu'il y a ça aussi voilà donc
après oui mais monsieur parle de
communauté à chaque fois vous avez fait
une vidéo qui s'appelle quelle
communauté est la plus difficile à gérer
à l'entrée d'une discothèque donc là
vous vous essentialiser les le problème
en disant les problèmes viennent parce
que ils sont issus de telle ou telle
communauté c'est
l'ffich r droit oui elle il peut
répondre Oui bien en fait je ne parle
que de ce qu'on vit d'accord c'estd
qu'en fait je je me moque de savoir ce
que les gens vont penser en fait j'ai
rien à vendre j'ai je suis pas politisé
enfin j'ai rien à vendre je veux je
montre juste ce qui se passe je
l'affiche et je le prouve c'estd qu'en
fait je je je peux mettre je peux vous
aligner un an tout est nous fiché
organisé filmé voilà je peux vous
aligner un an de ce qui nous arrive et
et vous prouver ce que je vous dis j'ai
un un journaliste qui est venu il y a
pas très très longtemps qui a fait un
magnifique article à la base c'est un
journaliste de gauche qui est venu me
voir au début c'était plutôt à charge on
a discuté un restaurant Gill c'est
important ce que je vais je vais vous
dire là parce Queen fait ça ça fait
comprendre la chose le journaliste il
est pas d'accord avec moi et tout voilà
je lui SRE la main je lui dis je vous
propose quelque chose venez avec moi la
nuit la prochaine nuit vous la faites
avec moi et j'aurai pas besoin de vous
convaincre ce qui se passera va vous
convaincre il a mis 1h30 à être
convaincu pouvez pas amener g Vernez
1h30 ouais non mais sans rigoler non
mais c'est c'est c'est incroyable c'est
que au bout d'
1h30 il a compris que c'est lui qui fait
le bordel dans la boîte c'est un
exercice intéressant et et il a compris
en fait au bout d' 1h30 d'ailleurs il a
pas pu dormir comprendre que quand il
est parti de la boîte il a même pas pu
dormir tellement ça l'avait stressé il a
pu attendre que la nuit suivante il m'a
appelé en me disant mais j'ai jamais été
autant entendu en fait j'ai j'avais pas
imaginé que ça pouvait être comme ça en
fait ben en fait il y a que quand on le
vit qu'on le comprend et malheureusement
euh c'est c'est c'est pas grave en vrai
Gill je je parle je parle à vous parce
que je vois que c'est vous le plus
énervé là mais c'est pas grave c'est
juste que il faut y trouver des
solutions comment on fait pourquoi
est-ce que j'arrive à faire rentrer
certains groupes de Maghrébins je le
redis quand il rentre j'ai une SA Hipop
j'en ai plein magrbins ils m'en veulent
pas de dire ça quand ils
arrivent non mais en plus il consomment
beaucoup ils sont ils font la fête ai B
quand même oui pardon mais tout à
l'heure vous dis j'ai des blages qui
vont dans une salle Hipop les magrébens
vienent en groupe on on dirait que
vous arrête un peu arrê
un second réond totalement d'accord avec
votre diagnostic sur justement l'hyper
violence aujourd'hui de la société on la
commente nous tous les jours ici ensuite
le procédé de vous disqualifier de fait
parce que sous prétexte que vous vous
parleriez d'une réalité qui est votre
réalité d'un sorte de dénis aujourd'hui
idéologique des bien pensants qui disent
non mais c'est pas possible ça parce
qu'il est raciste parce qu'il est c'est
insupportable c'estàdire que si la
France va aussi mal c'est parce qu'en
fait à mon avis on n'ose pas si nommer
les choses et dire ce qui se passe dans
la réalité la raison pour laquelle je
mets nom c'est qu'en fait là vous
devenez vous une sorte de justicier que
c'est vous aujourd'hui avec votre code
pénal à vous qui va dire lui il est
délinquant lui il est pas délinquant
selon ma charte à moi selon mon regard à
moi selon moi ma volonté lui non lui non
lui ça passe en revanche lui c'est
insupportable donc en fait moi je ne
sais pas en fait quel est votre votre
curseur de jugement voyez par rapport à
ça et je TR en boite ouais oui mais sauf
que c'est dangereux parce que à ce
momentl si quelqu'un met une main par
exemple à aux fesses d'une nana c'est un
délinquant il sort donc vous l'affichez
vous l'affichez pas vous l'affichez pas
moi par exemple je considère que c'est
grave voilà quelqu'un par exemple qui va
je sais pas pousser un gars et lui
renverser un un peu de manière violente
un je sais pas un verre de whisky à la
gueule c'est un délinquant ou c'est pas
un délinquant ce sera pas montré ça
voilà donc mais voyez ce que je veux
dire c'est que votre curseur à partir de
quand vous considérez effectivement que
c'est vraiment un délinquant donne je
sais pas évidment de la drogue ou des
trucs comme ça
en fait dès que ça met physiquement en
danger quelqu'un en fait c'estd que une
fille qui prend une cul ça la oui
d'accord mais ça ça ça nous arrive assez
fréquemment on estbl de le gérer si je
commence à montrer tout je vous fais une
série télé et là vous allez vous dire ça
devient compliqué en fait en fait
j'essaie de montrer vraiment quand à un
moment donné les choses se sont passées
d'une façon telle et d'ailleurs on parle
vous parlez de justice à chaque fois il
y a une raison judiciaire je fais jamais
ça au hasard quand je fais un affichage
réel c'est c'est qu'on a un problème
justement au niveau de la justice c'est
qu'il va falloir qu'on le règle
rapidement soit parce que je sais que ça
va rien donner et que la personne a été
une vraie victime et que je sais très
bien que dans 6h qui vont suivre ou 8h
la garde à vue va être finie et
l'histoire va être pliée dernièrement
c'était au mois de novembre que j'ai
eucal là avec deux gros deux blessés
graves qui se sont retrouvés à 6h30
enfin 6h30 du matin la la discothèque
était même fermée et et les les gars ont
essayé de prendre la fuite on les a
rattrapé quand je vous dis des graves
blessés il y en avait un qui avait une
épaule déboitée la tête dévisagée parce
qu'ils ont sauter sur son crâne et tout
enfin bref il y a pas besoin d'être
unjusticier pour se rendre compte que ce
qui vient de se passer là c'est
inadmissible et je souhaite ça à aucun
père ou mère de famille quand j'arrive
là je me dis mais ça pourrait être mon
gamin quoi défoncé à 6 et là à 18h le
soir j'apprend que le procureur avait
plié l'affaire c'était une ris de
discothèque j'ai pas pu j'ai mis des
vidéos le lendemain la la la le
lendemain l'enquête avait été rouverte
et là ils ont attrapé effectivement les
gars non je pense que vous dénoncez les
inivités que vous avez envie de dénoncer
pour servir votre idéologie et je
reparle de cette vidéo dans laquelle
vous parlez de communauté où vous dites
en synthèse les Asiatiques sont gentils
les Arabes sont méchants les Français ça
va donc si vous entendu les autres sont
pas français voilà et les commentaires
allez voir les commentaires c'est ah
toujours les mêmes ah il a dit voilà
dans la vidéo ah voilà et cetera et
cetera donc je pense que c'est très bien
moi je suis pour à la base un commerçant
qui montre la tête d'un délinquant pour
qu'il soit retrouvé pour qu'on dise lui
faites attention c'est un voleur ok
quand c'est pour servir une idéologie et
j'ai vu une autre vidéo dans lequ dans
laquelle vous parlez d'une personne
noire et vous avez dit ah j'ai j'ai j'ai
un ami c'est un renois mais c'est c'est
un mec bien c'est sousentendu les autres
noirs sont problématiques il y a un truc
qui met mal à l'aise dans vos vidéos
voilà c'est vous qui faites ces
sous-entendus là en fait on peut plus
dire j'ai un copain blanc il est génial
ça ça passe par contre quand on pas dire
j'ai un copain renois qui est génial s
entendu les autres sont ne sont pas Gén
c'est la manère don vous dites j'ai un
ami vous dites texto j'ai un ami Renoir
ça va il est pas problématique et ca non
je dis pas ça on va revenir làdessus
dans dans un instant les chér puis on
aura le scoop de Paul Sky pu on aura un
témoignage très très fort on va mourir
ensemble le chauffeur de taxi pris en
otage par le terroriste de Strasbourg ça
c'est c'est un témoignage incroyable qui
va être dans TPMP en direct dans un
instant à tout de
suite